that is good
for sure what a shot
devin booker today
puts the sons now three and oh
in the bubble they need help to make the
playoffs for that play-in game
they confirmed they are learning a lot
in a short while here
look at the defensive line paul george
let me tell you something
there's no way that paul george could
have played any better
defense than that watch the freeze move
here little jab step
[Applause]
in a blink of an eye look at this pump
fake
just mcmillan said before the game that
he would use betaze who's battled some
knee soreness
you have to stay disciplined on devin
booker
look at devin booker there's one dribble
look at the gather
the float right look he's measuring them
well
see him your measurements are a little
off
drive here i mean you're going right
your angle is not the best
he's sailing out of bounds 40 from
beyond the arc
and that's when you kind of felt like
okay his
leg strength is back as booker goes
right at him with the left hand
he's coming downhill at you just light
up when a young guy jumps out there
[Music]
trying to fight over the screen
[Music]
beautiful stroke there from devin booker
who's got 14 now
shooting 51 from the floor including 10
of 17
from distance 4 6 10 of 17 from the
free-throw line here is booker for three
[Applause]
rubio shadowed by jackson
leonard invites booker baseline he
decides to pull the trigger on a three
and knock it in five of a kind
for devin he was making against the
mavericks on sunday
[Applause]
book leaning back on the baseline cash
it in
another 30 plus point game the game is
never over with
you talk about a light switch they just
turned on the switch and got
very very serious defensively big time
shot by eaton what a ball game here six
to play
[Applause]
booker this is for the win got it
wow
[Applause]
that's what devon has to do if he wants
to stay in the game it's just
back to the basics left right
over it's a trust factor some players
they allow to get away with it some they
don't workers their leading scorer he's
very good attacking from the wings he's
shorter
than the 6-11-8 competed on the ball
there
bam bobbled it and lost it to devin
booker first turnover
for miami tonight booker on the run
banked it in he wanted the foul
into the hands of mikael bridges eight
for the cutting booker buries it devin
booker
three-point shooting has not been there
consistently tonight for
for miami five out of 16. booker
moving and making
that's a big help there for the suns
ford makes a catch in the corner heroes
good close-up
[Applause]
five on the shotgun booker
[Applause]
he is a machine right now he has
29 points
booker receives this off a rubio driving
kick again he drew two defend
and a quick 7-2 oklahoma city lead
booker on the drive goes glass
smooth shooter look explodes to the
right
mentally you just let your guard down
this is something the sons are going to
really fight here in the first half
book on the turnaround opportunity to go
always where he wanted to go
baseline rookie trying to play games on
him
for some different ways a lot of things
over there
look at that i mean he said half court
back to bridges and here's the
last play booker on the truck booker is
a guy who gets his steps down
and goes left people forget that he goes
strong left he's made two lefty layups
here tonight look at this
waits for the defense comes on up there
look at the contact
yep two-time national champion for jay
wright's
villanova wildcats booker doubled faking
and jumping over the frame
we jumped over two guys including
marjanovic right in front of him and at
14 it's down to nine
and phoenix has done a lot of this this
7-0 start
probably will go to 8-0 without aaron
baines
brooker with it played in kentucky for a
season
look at that nice fake and he drops the
sledgehammer pretty play
by kevin booker